All right, kid.
Hang on.
You ready for an adventure?
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This will be My Mandalorian
Season 3 Episode 7 Trailer Video
There's a bunch of Easter Eggs.
And a bunch of storylines
that they still have to pay off
in their teasing, a whole bunch of stuff.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
I will also be doing Ahsoka episodes
that'll be coming later this year.
We'll get a trailer for that really soon.
I believe they're waiting for Star Wars
celebration.
Rosario Dawson was teasing
that she was going to be at Star Wars
celebration, revealing some big stuff.
I believe at some point
during the last couple of episodes
of The Mandalorian they'll tease the Ahsoka
series like they'll be in Ahsoka cameo.
Maybe Sabine Wren will cameo.
Just to help set that up, Dave
Filoni has been treating the Ahsoka series
like his own baby.
He wrote, and he directed pretty much
all the episodes on The Mandalorian.
Usually when he helps out with episodes
like he writes an episode
or he directs an episode, it's
because they're either
dealing with characters that he originated
or there's something important
from one of his characters in the episode,
like when they had the Zeb cameo,
Dave Filoni helped write that episode.
He also cameoed in that is his Trapper
Wolf character, along with the other
Mandalorian directors
like Deborah Challenge Rick from up.
I believe he also helped
work on Mandalorian.
Episode seven, maybe Episode eight.
We'll see.
I can't remember which episode it was.
So that means they'll probably be
some big Dave Filoni type of moment,
like an a soldier type of moment
or something close to that.
But at the end of The Mandalorian
Episode
six, Mando slid through on a technicality,
and everybody's still kind of wondering
about why they pulled it off this way.
Use it to give Bo-Katan the Darksaber back
without having to fight her
in honorable combat,
which normally would be how mandalorians
deal with the ownership of the darksaber
like, okay, duke it out.
Whoever wins owns the Darksaber
they literally just did that
between AX wolves in Bo-Katan with her
winning back the night owls,
or at least leadership of the night owls.
So you follow me
then they had the whole darksaber moment.
Mando claiming that during episode two
and the scavenger trapped in by surprise,
the darksaber fell to the ground
and just lay there
until Bo-Katan picked it up
while she was fighting the scavenger off.
And that was enough to qualify per
their rules of transfer of ownership, her
winning it from the scavenger
and then claim ownership herself.
Everyone's making jokes about Harry Potter
and the elder one rules.
We're during the Harry Potter series,
the movies they dealt with the ownership
of the Deathly Hallows,
the ultra powerful elder wand the same way
claiming that Harry Potter
became the actual owner.
Thanks to a series of technicalities
and overlooked circumstances.
I think the way they pulled it off
in the Harry Potter
movie was a little more satisfying.
Like a ha Dumbledore allowing Draco Malfoy
to disarm him so that
technically he would briefly become owner
the elder one without realizing.
And Dumbledore knowing that later,
when Harry Potter defeated Draco,
that would make him the true owner
by the rules of the elder wand.
I think in the case of the darksaber,
they're bending over backwards
a little more than they did
in the Harry Potter movies, and it didn't
feel quite as triumphant of a moment
as they probably wanted it to.
It was meant to be a callback to the being
ren giving the Darksaber to Bo-Katan
during Star Wars rebels
after the heroes of Mandalore story arc
where she rallied
all the mandalorians together.
They wanted the moment
to feel kind of like that
because in present day Bo-Katan is doing
basically the same thing she did
at the end of that Rebels episode,
bringing all the Mandalorians together
different clans,
but what they might be doing
with the live Action
Mandalorian series during season three
and this gets into Episode
seven and Episode eight, the finale
is that while Bo-Katan is finishing
convincing all the rest of the Major
Mandalorian clans
to rally together on the Mandalore planet,
and they all get ready to witness
the living mythos, all
with their own eyes.
Well, people are forgetting
is the Moff Gideon storyline.
Like obviously huge character
and we haven't picked up with him
since that teaser
at the end of the last episode.
And people are forgetting that Moff Gideon
won the Darksaber from Bo-Katan before.
At some point,
before or after the Great Purge,
they just tease Moff
Gideon having that big rally moment
like he knew that he would be captured
the whole time he had this grand plan,
a contingency that he made for it,
and he might just be waiting
for the Mandalorians to come together,
like all come together in one place,
and for Bo-Katan to get the darksaber back
so that he can challenge her in combat
and also win the darksaber
back on a technicality like Bo-Katan
won it on a technicality
so that the moment at the end of episode
six becomes more foreshadowing for the way
Moff Gideon tries to win over
some of the mandalorians to his cause.
Here's where we get into Darth Maul
wielding the Darksaber during the Clone
Wars. A lot of people wondering
how did moff
Gideon
get the Darksaber in the first place?
The way he mocked
The Mandalorian in Bo-Katan after
he defeated him about the rules
of the Darksaber made it sound like Moff
Gideon won the Darksaber from Bo-Katan
the right way, the correct way in combat.
Somehow,
even if there was some technicalities,
he doesn't actually seem
like a physical match for her.
He might have just had some crazy weapons
during their fight.
And when he won it in the past,
it was probably a moment
kind of like Darth Maul winning
the Darksaber during the Clone Wars
with the threat of something
similar happening again in the future,
threatening the mandalorians
all coming together.
Maybe Moff Gideon
also has a contingency plan for that too.
When Darth Maul won the Darksaber
from previously during the Clone Wars,
also played by Jon Favreau
like he plays the heavy infantryman
Paz Vizsla during present day,
probably the child or the nephew
or somehow related to pre-viz.
When Darth Maul defeated him
winning the darksaber, it was in clear
sight of a bunch of mandalorians
like they were witnessed.
He did it in honorable combat
with his lightsaber.
There wasn't any trickery at play,
so when he won the challenge
a bunch of the mandalorians not bo-katan,
but some of them swore
fealty to Darth Maul
becoming the Maul delorean's
with the point that helmets that look
kind of like the armored helmet.
A lot of people now wondering if the armor
has some history with Darth Maul.
People have been wondering
this since season one
if she might have been a maul DeLorean
during the Clone Wars
because she's about the same age
as Bo-Katan.
So she would have been around
for those events
during the Clone Wars, when Darth
Maul briefly wielded the darksaber in.
She has appointed helmet that looks
just like there's what Emily Swallow.
The actress who plays
the armor said about her true purpose.
Her back story
is that she doesn't want power herself.
She just wants all Mandalorians to follow
what she considers to be the true way,
the way of the original mandalore,
and to help Mando
find his true
potential as well as Bo-Katan.
So the armor at least believes
that she's doing what she thinks is best
for the Mandalorian culture.
That doesn't mean
that she's being completely honest,
revealing everything to Mando and Bo-Katan
like she might have some ulterior motives
in asking them to do certain things,
but she's doing it at least in service
of the Greater Mandalorian culture.
In the funny thing about Moff Gideon
is that Jean Carlo Esposito said that he's
always got plans in motion no matter what
you see happen to him during season one.
Season two, even though he was captured,
he had contingency plans for that.
And he has a grand plan for the future
of the galaxy that he's trying to enact.
So even though it seems like
he got his ass kicked
at the end of season two, Jean
Carlo Esposito is saying that.
No, no, no.
You don't realize he's
actually got plans for this.
So it just seems like things happening
so conveniently.
All the mandalorians coming together
so easily.
These last couple of episodes heading into
the finale is just a ploy in Moff.
Gideon has some contingency plans.
He's cooking up in the background. Like,
what is he cooking?
Let him cook.
I know there's still tons of questions
about Grand
Admiral Thrawn
and his connection to Moff Gideon
because they are both representatives
of the remnants of the Empire.
But Grand Admiral
Thrawn is like a much bigger,
overarching thing,
and he's still sort of waiting at bay.
I think he might have something
to do with Moff Gideon right now,
but right now
that's still in the background.
This is just continue
teasing that out through the finale
and we'll find out
more about it during the Ahsoka series.
But he'll be a much bigger character
during the Ahsoka series.
There's still that mystery fleet of the
tie fighters, Tyner centers, tie bombers.
I think that's connected
to the remnants of Moff Gideon forces
that are still out there in the outer
rim in Grand Admiral Thrawn seventh Fleet.
We'll probably follow up with that,
find out where they actually came from.
I'm still holding out hope for an Ahsoka
in a Sabine Wren cameo.
I think it's more likely
that Ahsoka would cameo.
I don't know if Sabine Wren
would also cameo as well,
but the timing of when they announced
the Sabine Wren actress just makes
it sound like they cast her in time
to film scenes for The Mandalorian
when they were still filming Season three
before they started filming the Ahsoka
series.
There's still the whole subplot with Dr.
Pershing and Elliot Kane back on course.
Aren't a lot of people thought
that she actually killed Dr. Pershing?
I don't think that's the case.
I think that just remains
to be a hanging plot thread.
They'll pick up with that
before the end of the season.
The whole idea is I think she was trying
to erase all of his memories about her
so that he wouldn't
be able to inform on her
because it did seem
like he genuinely wanted to turn good.
And she's just been pretending
to be reformed
sitting inside that requisition office
so that she can keep tabs on everything
the New Republic is doing so that
she can help the remnants of the Empire.
Moff Gideon Grand Admiral Thrawn likes.
He specifically wanted to keep
the New Republic away from the outer rim
so that they wouldn't
be poking around out there and find
any of the remnants of the empire.
There's also that funny
hanging plot thread with IG 11.
Like that funny Terminator plot.
Are they going to fix his body?
Will Mando find the Memory Corps
or are they going to do something
completely different with the storyline?
I don't expect Taika Waititi
to permanently come back to the show,
so I think there'll be some funny left
turn with IG 11 storyline where they use
the parts of his body for something else
for Grogu or one of the other characters,
like they'll pay off the storyline
in some different type of way.
Like they won't restore him completely.
They'll use his body for something
completely different.
They've been teasing Grogu
becoming a mandalorian,
getting all this special extra tech
weaponry and armor.
Maybe it'll have something
to do with Grogu getting more upgrades,
even though Mando currently
doesn't have the Darksaber anymore.
That's kind of a bummer.
Was kind of hoping to see him use
the Darksaber while writing the mythos, or
I still think that he will
eventually write the myth
or we'll see
if anybody does that during the family.
They might push that into season four.
I think the whole twist with Grogu
using the force on the rancor
at the end of the book of Boba Fett
was meant to set up him
doing the same thing with the mythos or
but they've been teasing that
Bo-Katan has been getting closer
and closer with Grogu becoming
kind of like his surrogate space mom.
The way that he views
Mando is a surrogate father.
They're teasing them
as sort of like this little family unit.
They all three might write the mythos
or just because it's so huge,
you could probably put like
ten mandalorians
on the back of the mythos or that's
how big it is.
I just really hope that
in some future season we get to see them
using the myth of Thor in battle,
just destroying a bunch of imperial ships.
There's still a whole bunch
other plot threads, a bunch of teasers
that they haven't paid off yet.
So if there's anything
that I didn't address in this video
that you're still wondering about
before the end of the season,
just write it below in the comments.
Remember, there's two episodes
left as a me posting this video.
There's a bunch of other trailers,
a bunch of stuff that happened this week.
I'll try to make videos for everything
the next couple of days.
Be sure to enable orders for my channel
so you don't miss that.
My full episode seven video will post
next week after they release it.
You can click here for that.
I'll update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other Mandalorian
Episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.